I'm to go and raise money spirit back
welcome back to chapter 2 of impossible
book two three
I think that was right fact of the day
prepare for unseen consequences that's
not a fact you pieces I think we know
that just by it is that what I'm saying
you know the jizz it's [ __ ] weird man
so let's just begin
there you go shafter to miss sorry picks
up where I left off where Chris was
strangled by a tentacle from space press
x to jason Danny John what the [ __ ] you
got game over on the first one I'm
surprised like how much better at the
game is than I actually expected it to
be the first time I played in look he
has boobs I mean he has a book also I
did a rhyme look he has a book ha ha ha
we can probably eat him he looks quite
delicious under all that ginger fuzz hmm
we'll do 40 to stop with the rhymes 109
that [ __ ] parfaits what the hell boy
roll over will ya
I can see units meow I'm Norman
I'm your cell next door and you sir are
our ticket to get out of here we do you
see that just the old book over there
sir one of the Gods left it there a few
months ago while cleaning at the cell
it's a copy of the love mites guide to
the galaxy but my wife's brains are able
to store information of any kind that's
stupid that's sort of like my brain holy
[ __ ] so instead they started on an
all-electronic encyclopedia that book
contains everything every flop which
live in universe knows including the key
code for that door you probably had to
answer a few questions but how hard
could it be our god damn it Jason
you gotta nice it's a good dictionary
toilets ain't it what what the hell did
it say so we left all that at 50 so we I
guess we have peeps Tamura dude dude I'm
using in this one
it's pretty sweet how many bits in a
byte depends on the size of your map
high score you win all 69 hello score oh
I get it I get it how do you load as the
slapper Trump with your fists
but load click the dots they aren't
really dots that squeeze and that one to
define us mostly harmless what what is
this all of the above
gene yes which of these is harmful the
Hedgehog crabmeat obviously how do you
win an extra guy remove the cartridge
and blow it Oh No
[Laughter]
let's try again
that was pretty good for a first try
holy [ __ ] I don't get this one flat what
which [ __ ] flat do i click
what diff which [ __ ] fun ten print
fun what the hell does that even mean
shut up of a [ __ ] sake what one one out
what the [ __ ] is this
I don't even get time to celebrate I'm
probably gonna make a dick or something
but if I click here what I buy here what
a buy here night is being made how much
busting oh oh
the 59 is the square one two three four
five six seven
ah it's time for what
vlog oh okay extremely intelligent if I
got effect [ __ ] yeah
how do I win basted
he's been - Venus he's been action veena
heavens he must update to continue no
gosh [ __ ] sake
fine Paulo that [ __ ] like the music but
what the [ __ ] is going on
what in the name of heavens do you think
you're doing Shh what shall we play
I quite fancy a game of strip poker sure
strip poker unable to stop missing
variable gotta stop fighting around and
get a move on I don't hate you there it
is loader loader whatever load always
checked what was happening
oh god how many colors in the cut
spectrum
fifteen oh nice solo Brown what the hell
that I just Oh God
timer how do you get rid of the red by a
few stray oh come on
here's a have it there's a cream ah but
I can't help dancing I can't help let's
go guys I'm sorry
so how did I do that I press up watch I
don't what what is the first book of the
Bible : in Europe and Japan the Big Bang
what chapter 1 why the Megadrive okay of
course of course I knew that what is the
name of the prequel to Metal Gear Solid
Snake's on a plane oh come on Metal Gear
flies it which planet is farthest from
the Sun Pluto's not a planet
yeah poor Pluto c+ i equals sun cream
it's blue + yellow equals green white
salad cream come on now you're just
[ __ ] with me 50/50 baby see obviously
sends for carrot in I obviously stands
for I don't [ __ ] know and there was
one I think yes there was one time a
carrot called I I roamed
it was then that by her mom salad cream
and salad crane was always on top of
things to the left or then to the right
and then it would jump up all around and
if you combine care
with I don't [ __ ] know what do you
get exactly exactly it's loaded loading
it takes you a while to process that
[ __ ] you think it's loading you think it
is loading charrids because I don't
[ __ ] know it's obviously a home in in
Pennsylvania which is a residential area
for people so you think that's what it
is but it took you a while to think of
that thing so it's loading you were
loading that [ __ ]
but while you were loading that [ __ ] you
realize it was rest flawless logic oh
[ __ ] now for [ __ ] sake you haven't I
talked to the brows don't distract me
again yeah that's not picking your nose
still that's rude I said stop dirty I
won't again destroy the soft blocks but
how how Oh
what what all 69 armpit fetus bum cheeks
sausage wrong bum cheeks what I was so
sure don't you Dave / facepalm yes I've
caught Oh for [ __ ] sake I don't know
how I solved it I did it I get I don't
know how how do I do it it has to be
goddamn it alright let's think
I think 69 was coming clear a number
where it was okay to not shave your
armpit there's also a year where fetuses
were rolling sausage rolls I think or is
it armpits and now you're now you're
just confusing the armpits my god dammit
I had a life boy
a lifebuoy boy had a lifebuoy where's my
lab boy boy boy give me a light boy hey
boy over there boy
give me a light boy boy boy gimme light
boy boy boy boy boy boy light boy you're
a nurse it's bleeding funny now for [ __ ]
sake I was reading I was reading the
pocket bull did you put that and this is
how your reward I would sell on this one
seriously armpits sausage penis bomb
chicks hate it
you tricked me Oh what I would have to
click there 69 times how guys is old
already
yeah it was like that back Frank
I got damnit use arrow keys to move eat
all the tasty globs don't get mauled by
their ghost
oh [ __ ] I'm bad at this oh no no no
it's not it's hard man break it down now
to me girl right break it down now to me
so far not some [ __ ] man oh god oh
god oh why do you have to be that no do
it again really let new farmer fun you
must update to continue click update to
update
[Music]
okay we're on 31 that which country her
dues is defined as Prabhas in the world
has to be in Li right cuz Mario yeah
hahaha but no no no don't blow up in my
face please of a [ __ ] a girl but I love
the music it's social
I think this clip is my favorite out of
all of them that could change quickly
it's [ __ ] quicker than me what am I
supposed to do fun no that's fun
Oh ash on
goddamnit God [ __ ] Pac Man Man Man
Matt hunts new gaming rod
[Music]
come on baby or yell yes ah took me
forever to get back here it's not funny
[Music]
what how many letters shameless yeah I
would have caused a 1-up ha ha ha ha
let's see how my math is should we I
don't know I'm fun doing the right thing
I don't care I'm obviously not doing the
right now come on so close so close no
oh what lag Pisces manutaki fix my
eyebrows
all better now pac-man more like [ __ ] me
in the ass man [ __ ] this one's hard it's
an anagram for lives [ __ ] oh [ __ ] save
[Music]
come on come one ha ha life is life no
no no no go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
it's okay I don't care about losing Oh
God not this [ __ ] man [ __ ] every [ __ ]
the world [ __ ] the world
[ __ ] them it's not even a question ask
me ask me anything ask me anything
don't put me up oh my god flawless floor
[ __ ] lace then you're retiring off
now [ __ ] the air ah yeah never happen
which epic sword do you need to defeat
yog let Salman I don't [ __ ] you know
testa column not more games please now
who the [ __ ] good man
the [ __ ] is a splode
[Music]
Oh buddy Jabba Victor of acute cannister
fun oh good Oh God
oh good oh yeah good thing I can reach
over there you I [ __ ] you
social dick thank God I didn't kill that
[ __ ] Oh God
five five
you must update the Contini god it's
like my own internet this is me
uploading videos except that [ __ ]
[ __ ] doesn't move by the full game for
only 160 quiz point but I feel like a
good offer
oh well that was cheap okay what is my
games great achievement well it's
[ __ ] a language and [ __ ] a
medicine and it sure as hell it's a
limitation no not gone what the [ __ ]
oh my god I really don't want to fail
now bit agrees it's a trap
carnage Africa free car I free huh
Oh God Oh God play it again I hate you
aah holy always a javelin are a chicken
aah not really no big deal at all
because I don't care that digest -
coffin what the [ __ ]
obviously 42 kill him kill him yeah but
like that's [ __ ] possible don't copy
me what do i what am I gonna do what am
I doing here
what what how do you start a hedgehog
race say God I flow much I two
approaches fight
oh no not pokeballs not goddamn [ __ ] ah
[Laughter]
I'm not baking anything but bacon
scratch face table you can't
you hallucinate / oppress that's all the
time I had for playing today I'm gonna
try to finish this next one there's one
chapter after after all so holy [ __ ] man
this is so difficult
we're gonna do it next cuz if I don't
stop now I might just hurt somebody but
live like you enjoy watching anyway it's
the SkyDome road today see buzzing next
one stay awesome love you
[Music]
you
oh my god flawless floor [ __ ] lace
and you're retiring